I
Need to do yes
You're gonna need to read your own performance, but you can once you're ready, okay, do it
Oh
Like I love
Okay, you're gonna read what you're feeling and thinking each moment
Okay, can I can I go back go back no we cannot
I don't think so. Okay. Yeah, let's just just continue
Okay, well when I was doing this my mind was probably the most clear. Okay. It was kind of like a reset
Okay
That part I was like trying to focus
I paused there a little bit because I wasn't sure what to do next
I couldn't remember if I had to keep a fist open
I think I finished just somewhat in the same spot
So
Let me get that number so with this one, obviously
Oh score so as you can see
Your pattern is scored
Based on the number 10. So out of 10 is your is your mark
As you can see it's split